everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at game 19 from the 1972 World
Chess Championship between the champion
buddy Spassky in the challenger Bobby
Fischer from the United States this was
a best of 24 series and the entire
series was deemed the match of the
century but in game 19 we have white
playing from Spassky and he's down three
points to Bobby Fischer buddy Spassky
has his work cut out for him because
best of 24 there's not a lot of games
left to make up three points especially
since Bobby Fischer has been favoring
just going for drawls not trying to go
down any crazy lines it could get him in
trouble just content with getting the
draws and getting closer and closer to
the World Championship so we're going to
get started from white Spassky plays
pawn to e4 Knight to f6 so the Alekhine
defense something we don't see that
often but something Bobby Fischer
decided to throw out his opponent
there's not a lot of random openings
that he's never even played before but
decides to go ahead and bring them out
in the World Championship pawn to e5
forcing the knight to move to a d5 pawn
d4 pawn d6 trying to get rid of some of
the pressure in the center the board
also opens up the door for the
LightSquared bishop to get involved and
the knight to f3 this is the modern
variation it's the mainline sometimes
you'll see players play pawn to c4
forcing the knight to move back and then
they may even push even further
sometimes even with pawn to f4 after the
knight moves that is a very aggressive
way to play it one that you don't see
all that often just because it really
pushes your pawns without any defense
behind them from your minor pieces
usually you're gonna be seeing Knight to
f3 this is just a normal development
move also really hones down the control
of the dark squares in the center of the
board we see the bishop come down to g4
there's a risky variation if black
wanted to take here on e5 the knight
could recapture and then depending on
where black goes to sometimes we'll see
Knight to d7 trying to attack this
Knight but White has a
pretty interesting sacrifice here if
just Knight takes on f7 King takes and
then Queen up here to a tribe this is
check also for King attacking the knight
here on d5 so black would be forced
unless you want to go down a ton of
material to play King to e6 to hold on
to this material you can see although
black is up in material
he definitely has an exposed King and
White's gonna have a fun time choosing
this King around for the rest game
doesn't matter if it's Bishop to c4 just
pinning down the Knights whether it
wants to be just getting this dark
square Bishop involved castling on the
Queen side getting a rook here on e 1 to
start attacking there's not a lot of
great ways that black can continue and
still feel safe so in the game we see
Bob Fisher bring his Bishop down here to
g4 Bishop to e2 trying to stop some of
that pressure from the bishop pawn to e6
and then castle on the King side for
Spassky Fischer continues with Bishop to
e7 written to castle on the King side
pawn to h3 forcing the Bishop back here
pawn to c4 forcing the knight to come
back here to be six-night c3 symbol
development move castle on the King side
Bishop here to e3 pawn down to d5 upon
up here to c5 did have the option if he
wanted to exchange in the center bring
his rook over here to see one but
instead opted to try to just push in and
stop a lot of the squares that Bobby
Fischer could go to try to just choke
his opponent Bishop comes down here in
exchanges here on f3 a lot of times you
won't see a player exchange giving up
his Bishop for a Knights but recognizing
in this position specifically the
Knights just so strong controlling both
of the dark squares in the center of the
board so Bobby Fischer decides to go
ahead and exchange his knights for the
bishop also recognizing that this is a
closed structure and bishops tend to do
better in an open game where they can
have so many more squares to control but
right now Bobby Fischer looked at and
said yeah I'm okay
my Knights may even be better in this
position so I'm gonna continue and go
ahead and give up my bishop now decides
to bring his Knight down here to see for
this is a great little outpost also
since it was being
tact need to get that night to a safe
square pond to be three decides to go
ahead and exchange his nights here give
his opponents double pawns here on the
e-file well it's gonna be very easy for
Spassky to get rid of those double pawns
he could just play pawn to e4 there's no
way for black to really stop at getting
rid of those double pawns but pawn to b6
punt up here to e4 pawn down here to c6
pawn to b4 is have both sides just
trying to solidify their ponche making
sure that if one side takes that they
have pawns there that they can retake
here so this b files now an open file
that Spassky can easily bring us work
over here to be one to continue
it is a little tricky because Bobby
Fischer he doesn't have that same
flexibility he's going to need to get
his knight involved into the game where
if it gets his knight here to d7 that is
blocking off his queen from controlling
the center square he could bring it over
here to a6 but then it's not really
doing too much if it comes down here to
be four it's kind of all alone right
here and so it's gonna be interesting to
see how Bobby Fischer continues and gets
that Knight involved into the game queen
down here to a5 and then Knight takes on
d5 now if we count that Paul's in this
position here I really expected just the
Queen to move maybe Queen to e1 Queen to
d2 lots of these makes sense you want to
control this Knight right here still
control the center of the board and then
all of a sudden we see Spassky played
Knight takes on d5 and it looks like
this is gonna be a really weird exchange
usually you're gonna be seeing this if
he's thought through and that's exactly
what he has because it's so tough for
Bobby Fischer to take care and he really
can't and will go through the variations
if you were to take with a C pawn then
the pawn takes back here if the pawn
were to take then the Bishop takes and
you can see Bishop here on d5 attacking
this rook here on a8 can't really do
anything because it's blocked off by the
knight right there so Spassky doing a
good job of understanding that this
Knight is stopping this rook from
getting involved into the game now if we
come back and say what happens if the
other pawn takes so pawn from a six if
he takes okay pawn takes but still not
good
we know that the pond can't take right
here well okay we need to protect this
pond right here there's no good way to
do that there's no square that you can
really get to where that feels good even
if you have something like Queen to see
seven people try to hold on to this pond
we'll just punt up here to d6 that's not
gonna work for black he's gonna be
losing that material so this Queen here
on a5 although it came down to try to
get involved into the game really he
would like it back here to try to defend
so in the game after Knight takes on d5
Bobby Fischer decides to go completely
different route and just play Bishop to
g5 just say okay I recognized that I
made a mistake I gave up a pond of
material I'm gonna continue with my game
plan here so Bishop to g5 but you pup
here to h5 pawn takes now Bishop takes
on f7 so you see some crazy changes
going on from buddy Spassky saying yeah
you can't take with your king so I'm
okay if you want to take with your rook
here rook takes rook up here to f7 and
then Bobby Fischer says yeah let's go
ahead and get the Queen down here if you
want to exchange on board and that's
what they do this looks much more like
what Bobby Fischer wants exchange down
material he's no longer in a really
terrible position and he's getting more
towards the drawl state which he seems
to have been doing in the previous games
rook over here to f1 Knight to c6 now
opening up the door for his other rook
to get involved into the game pawn takes
on d5 pretty much have to take back with
the pawn rook to d7 Bishop up here to e3
and then King to h1 after the check from
Bobby Fischer and Spassky moving is King
to safety Bishop comes back here to d4
starting to gobble up some of those
pawns he does need to get back in this
game since his opponent has two rooks on
board pawn to e6 so white does have to
passed pawns he can start to push we see
black play Bishop to e5 if you look at
and say why doesn't he goblet material I
always have to be wary of your
opponent's rooks because we're over here
to see one as it is going to gobble up
one of these pieces on the board
even if rook to you
ates gobble up the bishop lose the pawn
buttons gonna lose the pawn here on d5
definitely going to be a good exchange
for Spassky so after pawn to e6 we see
Bishop to e5 rook takes on d5 rook over
here to e6 looking to gobble up material
rook to e1 attacking the bishop but the
bishop is being defended by this night
here on c6 so bishop or the rook can
easily come down to e6 take rook to d6
we see the King get involved into the
game would be a mistake if the bishop
were to take because Bishop takes and
then rook up here to e6 Bishop takes and
then the Knights gonna follow you can
see how bad this gets because this rook
is now attacking both of these minor
pieces if we come back and say what
happens if the rook takes okay well
that's gonna be bad as well pawn takes
here this is gonna be a dangerous pawn
to deal with and you see the same thing
if the bishop were to take then the rook
can just come up here to e6 now after
the pawn were to come here if we see the
King to f7 well then we see we're cover
here to c1 attacking the knight it just
gets tricky the rook can come up here to
c7 check start to gobble up some pawns
on the board so all in all do not want
to take that rook although it may look
tempting for Bobby Fischer to do so
decides instead it's better to get his
King involved into the game so King to
f7 rook takes on c6 rook takes and then
rook to e5 so we've come into the in
game with rooks apiece it does look like
White has an advantage but it's gonna be
fairly easy for Bobby Fischer to
actually gobble up a pawn back in
material and then both sides are really
equal there's no clear way for either
side to have an advantage we see Bobby
Fischer has the more advanced King so
he's gonna go ahead get that into the
action King here to f6
fortunately the rook to move King here
to e6 rook back to h5 and then pawn age
6 King to h2 rook to a6 so saying yeah
if I'm not gonna take this I can easily
take this pawn here on a2 there's no
real way for white to hold on to it so
he plays pawn to c6
as black decides to go ahead and take
this pawn here this allows passkey to
come over to a5 that's gonna be fine
pawn to a6 this blocks this pawn from
coming off the board but it does protect
and allows Spassky to hold on to his
pawn on the a file and this is just a
completely draw state they do have a
couple more moves King to g3 King f6
King f3 rook to c3 then after King to f2
and rook to c2 they decide to go ahead
and draw the game so after 40 moves we
do have another tie so game 19 at I felt
like Bobby Fischer this is exactly his
game playing right now especially with
the black pieces there's no reason to
give your opponent any hope that they're
gonna be coming back so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video we do have a few
more games left and the best of 24
series Bobby Fischer has still a 3 point
lead but thanks for watching I'll see
you in the next one